auch amerika hat ein einreise stopp
verhängt und genau dort wollen wir jetzt
hinschauen nach new york zu einem
kollegen herbert bauernebel aber du bist
sozusagen in der korona hölle der usa in
new york ist im absoluten
ausnahmezustand du bist jetzt im central
park was genau passiert dort gerade um
gegen die korona krise anzukämpfen
hier im center parcs wurde dieses
feldlazarette errichtet und einer
christlichen hilfsorganisation das ist
diese anlage ist nun fast fertig
allerdings man hat bereits mit patienten
gestern gerechnet
dazu ist es nicht gekommen es wurden
noch keine eingeliefert in diese anlage
die man hier hinter mir sie mit 68
spitalsbetten und ausrüstung wie auf
einer intensivstation
bedarf gebe es genug in new york die
spitäler quellen über mittlerweile
mittlerweile es kommt hier zu
dramatischen szenen ich habe gerade mit
einem befreundeten arzt telefoniert der
chronist in einem der spitäler in
brooklyn um der sagt die intensivstation
ist voll das spital ist voll er hätte
eine patientin die ja operieren muss mit
einer anderen leiden als corona virus
sie kann sogar ihr bein verlieren
das spital hatte mitgeteilt dass es
keine plätze keinen platz gibt für
weitere operationen so dramatisch ist
die lage bereits hier in new york wir
sehen hinter dir eben genau diese
zeltstadt die jetzt aufgebaut wird aber
in new york hat jetzt weitere maßnahmen
ergriffen um plätze zu schaffen kannst
uns da etwas mehr noch zu erzählen hat
man wird hier sehr kreativ weil man eben
so viele spitalsbetten neu schaffen muss
herstellen darf vom zehntausenden
weiteren spitalsbetten in den nächsten
tagen ausgebaut wurde das messezentrum
javits center
dort baut die nationalgarde ein spital
mit 2.000 betten es wurde sogar die
anlage wo die us open stattfinden in
flushing meadows die wird jetzt
ebenfalls adaptiert für ein weiteres not
spital für ebenfalls 2.000 betten auch
eine pferderennbahn in queens im adapter
auch dort soll ein spital entstehen
und natürlich es hier in der stadt
sorgen auch ganz dramatische meldungen
für unruhe und auch für panik es gibt
angeblich einen notfallplan der stadt
new york in dem häftlinge der
haftanstalt rikers island massengräber
aus ebenso zu diesem zeitpunkt sind wir
noch nicht in einem solchen szenario und
natürlich aber es gibt notfallpläne dass
es zu solchen wirklich furchtbar seien
entkommen könnte das heftige
massengräber schaufelt hier in new york